European Union environment ministers
have debated the impact of biofuels on
land use as the EU looks to introduce
new rules to encourage a shift to
biofuels that deliver greater greenhouse
savings as food prices rise and farmers
look to meet demand more land is being
cleared to grow crops that were once
planted in land where biofuels are now
produced The ministers agreed on the
need to address these competing needs
and in particular the negative impact of
biofuels but they differed in their
views on how best to resolve the problem
some raised concerns about the impact of
any changes on current investments and
that they might result in the less
efficient biofuels being imported into
Europe
during their meeting in Russells the
minister's also debated changes to the
way that environmental impact studies
are carried out the goals to improve the
effectiveness of the process without
adding too much bureaucratic red tape
they're in favor of reviewing and
addressing the environmental impact
assessment issues but they want to do so
to ensure that it is streamlined that is
efficient that it doesn't add
administrative burdens and it takes
account of the fact that there's a lot
of different consent processes already
in existence in various member states so
it is a quite a lot of work to be done
the minister's hope to be able to reach
an agreement on the reforms during the
second half of this year
the meeting also took stock of the reach
chemicals regulations five years after
they were introduced most countries
welcomed the European Commission's
attempts to reduce the burden of these
rules concerning hazardous chemicals on
small and medium-sized companies